sharif has taken oath as the 23rd prime
minister of pakistan
is declared to have been elected as the
prime minister of the islamic republic
of pakistan
sharif was elected with 174 votes after
imran khan was removed in a vote of no
confidence and the opposition boycotted
the election
if we are to save the sinking boat what
we all need is hard work and unity unity
and unity we are beginning a new era of
development today
known in pakistan as an administrator
who gets things done
at the age of 70 shabbat sharif was the
joint leader of the opposition that
toppled imran khan in a no confidence
vote
sharif entered politics and then led
pakistan's most populous province and
the major infrastructure projects
in his hometown lahore he successfully
brought in investment from china and
turkey
he's also had good relations with the
u.s analysts say he will need to mend
fences after the outgoing prime minister
accused his opponents of being
politically manipulated by washington
shahbaz is the younger brother of former
prime minister nima sharif who was
dismissed following allegations of
corruption
he is facing a money laundering case and
corruption charges brought by the
federal investigation agency and the
national accountability bureau both
brothers say the allegations leveled
under imran khan's premiership were
politically motivated and in 2007 sharif
criticized the accountability bureau
investigating him a nab
which is uh an institution
you know construed by sheriff eckland to
hitler's uh you know gestapo
national accountability bureau which
does selective accounting accountability
and other opposition politicians also
accused it of being a tool used for
political witch hunts in subsequent
years in power the muslim league
government left the bureau unchanged
out of all politicians shabbat sharif is
widely considered to be the most
acceptable to the military establishment
and those who came together to topple
imran khan's government are hoping that
the army will maintain what it calls its
neutral status
even if shaiba sharif remains the prime
minister until elections next year he
will still not become a prime minister
who completes a five-year term in
pakistan as none have done in the
country's 75 year history
islamabad